un poco más de un millón de personas
provenientes de Ucrania llegaron a
Alemania en el año 2022 según reveló la
oficina Federal de estadísticas de este
país que además explicó que alrededor
dos tercios de los inmigrantes llegaron
entre marzo y mayo del año pasado es
decir en los primeros meses de la guerra
una encuesta publicada a finales del año
pasado entre unos 11.000 migrantes
ucranianos reveló que una Clara mayoría
se sintió bienvenida a su llegada a
Alemania si bien también es Claro que
muchos piensan regresar a su país una
vez termine la guerra la encuesta reveló
que el 26% considera la posibilidad de
quedarse permanentemente en Alemania
Mientras tanto las autoridades siguen
discutiendo maneras en que puedan
mejorar el apoyo que reciben los
ucranianos aquí en Alemania algunas
ciudades que han dicho que están
llegando a sus límites por el alto
número de ucranianos y han pedido más
ayuda a las autoridades federales aquí
en Berlín ayuda no sólo logística sino
también financiera y de hecho este
jueves está prevista una Cumbre entre el
Gobierno Federal y los gobiernos
regionales para precisamente discutir
Cómo pueden seguir ayudando a los
refugiados no solamente en el plano
inmediato sino también a mediano y largo
plazo